um
we can't hear you hi
elia yes i'm going to be starting in one
more minute
thank you
last year
hello everyone and welcome to this
special session
on research project proposal by our
research fellows
and omix logic program participants
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors
and peers and enabling students and
researchers to develop
novel and independent research using
data science
to achieve this omics logic programs
follow a project based learning approach
using research grade tools to analyze
data from
top peer-reviewed journals this omics
logic training has been completed by
over 10 000 participants from
162 countries and over 300 workshops
for six specialization tracks like
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data
and comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics
can start developing a project of their
own
in fact we have already worked with many
students
who have completed this kind of training
and developed
interesting research projects that won
awards
and got published in peer-reviewed
journals
many of our past participants also had a
chance to present their analysis
in front of their classmates or at
conference
poster sessions in workshops
as we start with a review of the
presentations today
i want to introduce you all to dr
harpreet kaur
who would be sharing her feedback on the
projects
dr harpreet kaur is one of the trainers
who helps to facilitate many of the
sessions
her area of specialization is in
genomics
and machine learning she has over 16
peer-reviewed publications
and has been monitoring and mentoring
the omics logic
program participants over the past
several months
now let me introduce you to some of the
projects by
research fellows focused on alzheimer's
disease
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help
young researchers and students take
advantage of the bioinformatics
resources
for analysis of complex high throughput
life
science data and become versed in
mindful matrix
so this program offers you to
participate
in real and cutting-edge bioinformatics
research
and be part of a renowned bioinformatics
community
the first research fellow who is going
to be presenting
is andres so let us
see what andres has to say
okay uh my name is andres manos i'm a
high school student from mexico city and
i'm
currently doing
uh beeps it seems like we cannot hear
you muted yourself yeah okay i'll unmute
myself
generally mainly diseases
disease and my project is titled
basically a moment evaluating the role
of microbial cells in the pathogenesis
and progression of alzheimer's disease
and my mentor is dr harvey corp
so alzheimer's disease is an
irreversible and progressive brain
disorder
that results in the development of
cognitive deficits and clinical dementia
it is characterized by the development
of two pathological hallmarks
the first thing the development of
extracellular angular plaques
and the other one being uh intracellular
neurofibrillary tangles
uh although these are uh widely regarded
as a two main pathological homeworks of
alzheimer's disease
scientists still don't truly know how
they link to each other
and because of these uh they believe
that there
might may be other pathological
mechanisms that
underlie polyester pathogenesis and
progression of alzheimer's disease
and it is widely known that
patients with alzheimer's disease show
an increased inflammatory response
after they start developing amyloid beta
plagues
and this inflammatory response has also
been shown to exacerbate
the development of both neurofuel
or towel pathologies as well as a
development of these amyloid beta
plagues
and for this reason some scientists
believe that inflammation might be the
third core pathology of alzheimer's
disease thus providing a link between
the other two main pathological
conflicts
um well inflammation in the brain is
mediated by microglial cells which are
the brain's resident macrophages
which are part of our body's immune
system uh and because of this they have
been shown to mediate their inflammation
in the
in the brain by the secretion of chronic
inflammatory cytokines
uh and yes i had said uh so scientists
believe that these
neuroinflammation mediated by microglial
cells
might constitute this link between the
development of amyloidoplakes and the
further development of
neurofibrillary attacks
uh so for this project i wanted to
evaluate uh how the transcription of
microbial cells
uh buried uh through across eight across
like ph uh pessimise ah
and i used these data set from the study
transcriptomic profiling of microglia
industrial that
astrocytes throughout aging from the
journal of their information
so in here they used uh wild type and
apb ps1 mice uh adbps1 mice uh
show an elevated uh development of
amyloid beta plagues
uh because they like overproduce the
annular beta
peptide so they show a higher
development of the
of displays in here
uh and they use the 58 samples so uh
they have the uh sequence the
transcription of both microclient
astrocytes
uh in both wildlife and at mice the ad
mice are the
uh alzheimer's dc small mice so the atp
is one mice
uh and they will be yeah they sequence
the transcription at five different
uh time points so two months four months
six months
nine nine months and twelve months uh
and in the end they had 50 examples
uh i believe that the data from this
dataset provides
valuable information regarding microbial
activation
in response to aging with angular beta
pathologies because as i could say
these mice appears on mice facial
elevated levels of
amyloid beta plates and so we can really
see
how these angular beta breaks are
changing
uh the yeah the transcriptomic protocol
of microbial cells
and to see whether there is truly
another inflammatory response uh due to
the development of these
pathologies
uh so based on these files they provided
i
decided to just focus on the microglial
cells
i performed an rna-seq pipeline
uh so i quantify the gene expression
levels of microbial cells
was both across uh the wildlife and the
ad
and just uh as with any uh rna-seq
pipeline i pre-process the data then i
map the gamma-ray transcripts to the
organism's reference genome
and i then quantify the abundance of
reads aligned to the reference genome
so that i could get a gene expression
table
in returns in raw vitamins
uh and volusia obtained the expression
levels in
graphic games as an output and then i
used
this gene expression table as an input
or several differential expressions
uh and well it's based on this gene
expression a table that i got
i performed the following differential
expression analysis
using this f2 so the first one was young
ad versus old baby
so this will allow me to see uh how the
transcription of microbial cells uh
vary in pathological conditions as a
mice age
then young wildlife versus old wild type
this constitutes a reference
to which i could compare the first
differential expression analysis
as to see whether minds that are not in
pathological conditions
exhibit the same changes across aging or
if
the changes that i observed in the first
differential expression analysis
are just inherent to the pcs
yes then i did young wildlife versus
young ad
to see whether the transcriptomic
differences uh
between microbial cells in pathological
and physical physiological conditions
arise uh like from a young age whether
they arises in my speaking to
2h when they are older and then these uh
last one old wild type versus old lady
uh
to see uh the world yes the
transcriptomic differences between old
wildlife mice and all the
mice uh and to see like uh what are the
main
physiological differences between these
two
clinical groups um and just to
like explain how i defined young gay
young
mice as those that were uh two four and
six months old
because based on what i've read uh these
might start developing
amulet beta plates around uh six to
seven months old
when they are six to seven seven months
old and so i thought they would be
uh based on this observation i should
include the
the young mice uh s2 four then six month
old mice so that
build mice uh would be those that showed
a
truly elevated level of amyloid beta
breaks
and then after performing the
differential basic differential
expression analysis
uh i filtered the differential
expression i selected the differentially
expressed genes
for each analysis and you can really uh
like i think that this provides us an
insight into
when the uh transcriptomic changes
you could call them that all right so
you can see that between the young
wildlife and the young lady
we only have uh nine differentially
expressed genes so that really tells us
that
they are rather uh similar to each other
and that the physiological differences
appears in my speaking to age
and then when we compare the young lady
to the old baby we can see that there is
a
greater uh there's a greater number of
differentially expressed genes
in comparison to the young wildlife
versus old wildlife of course we
also see a rather related number but
this one's larger so
that maybe tells us that there is a
greater like
physiological divergence in terms of the
transcriptal
um yeah and so based on these
differentially expressed
expressions that i have gotten i perform
four different uh
principal component analysis with those
selected genes so with the
differentially expressed genes
so uh this one in here uh is from
uh the young lady versus old lady so
here we can see that
the old 80 mice are clustering to the
left side of the block whereas the uh
young mice or those from two to
two four and six months old mice are
clustering in here
uh so these are all ab mice uh so here
we found that uh one of the six month
old mice
is clustering uh like towards sealed
mice
uh which honest honestly isn't like that
surprising
because as i had said this maestro
developing diamond would be a
pathologist around like
six to seven months old and so maybe it
is my starting development
developing these pathologies when uh it
was perhaps
like uh younger because he of course is
very
decent like when they are six months old
it starts
but yeah then here i perform the young
wildlife versus the old world type
again uh here you can see that the two
four and six month old cholesterol
here where is an iota control plus
around here
but we don't see like such uh like it
isn't that polarized
uh and then from the
differentially expressed genes i
selected
those that showed uh well using luck to
pull
those that were uh like over express and
those that were underexpressed
uh based on these differential
expression analysis
and i could see that uh in the young av
versus the old lady
and also in the old world diverses the
ldd
we can see an increase in the activity
of neurotrophic degranulation
neurotrophic activation involving immune
response neurotrophic mediated immunity
and here we can see those same things
and then we can also
see here uh the inflammatory response uh
positive regulation of acute
inflammatory response
positive regulation of inflammatory
response regulation of inflammatory
response
positive regulation of cytokine
production cell digital mechanisms
involved in immune processes and
inflammatory mechanisms
which reinforces what we have what i
have stated in my
uh introduction uh
and when we compare that uh so when we
compare these differences
to uh the differences that arise when
comparing the young wildlife resources
we see that in here there will be an
inflammatory response or like
an increase uh in the immune processes
uh
so that really tells us uh that this is
uh
inherent to the pathological conditions
because we are not seeing that in here
uh and yeah as i had said the main
difference between the wild type mice
and the adpps one mice
is that the latter uh over produced
amyloid beta
and so they showed an incredible
increase levels of these
amino acids so this could tell us that
uh
the aggregation of these amyloid beta
plaques likely constitutes a cause of
microglial immune activation and as i
had previously said
this immune activation this
neuroinflammatory response in the brain
has been shown to exacerbate the
development of neurofibrillary tangles
so this really reinforces this uh like
a link between amyloid beta plates and
refrigerant angles and
that thing is like the snow inflammatory
response
and yeah so based on these mechanisms
that were uh
the most significant so narrow chocolate
the granulation director with activation
neurotrophic mediated immunity i tried
to research a little bit about the
water neutrophils i'm sorry i think that
i got said neurotropics
it's not tropical uh so
uh neutrophils are the most abundant
leukocytes so they are
white blood cells in circulation in the
circulation
they modulate immune processes and
they've been shown to play important
roles in biological information
and they are granulocytes which means
that uh
their cells uh there are type of white
blood cells that contain specific
granules which are some like vesicles
that contain
uh cytotoxic molecules as well as for
inflammatory cytokines
uh and then when they became uh
activated
uh they uh well yeah they can produce
reactive oxygen species which also
promote inflammation and it can also
lead to phagocytosis and the secretion
of pro-inflammatory cytokines
um and uh yes
and so what's next so as i get said i'm
glad
aggregation may induce the expression of
the secretion of pro-inflammatory
cytokines via
microglial cells in alzheimer's disease
but now i want to uh
investigate like what are the cellular
cellular and molecular mechanisms
that regulate the expression of these
cytokines
and uh long non-coding rnas are key gene
expression regulators in both innate and
adaptive immunity processes
the function of these molecules in
pathological processes however movements
are
largely unknown uh and they have been
shown to regulate the
indusible expression of cytokines after
immune activation
so now i want to answer this question uh
what are the roles of the
luminance coding are missing the
pathogenesis and disease preparation of
alzheimer's disease
are they involved in the regulation of
microbial activation states and thinner
information
in alzheimer's disease yes so
that is all thank you for your attention
so thank you everyone for listening into
andres's presentation
if you have any questions for andres
then please let us know and elia and dr
harpreet if you have anything to add so
please add to andres's presentation
i think it is nice presentation and he
has already
completed a lot of work so i think it is
very nice presentation
and maybe some of the text he can
decrease on his presentation
okay thank you so much dr harpreet for
that feedback
uh if you don't have any other questions
uh from the participants attending this
session
i will move on to the next slide so the
next
presentation i have is again by a
participant who is not
present today so this presentation is by
nathra
so both andres and netra is not present
because they have school today so
we are going to be seeing what they are
coming up with
so i'll play neetra's presentation now
hi everyone my name is netra srinivasan
and my project
is um the effects of the onset of
menopause on the transcriptomic profile
of the aging female brain
first of all to start off with the
significance of the problem there
appears to be a divergence in the
occurrence of
neurodegenerative diseases between men
and women but the mechanisms so far
are unknown for example for alzheimer's
disease more than 5.5 million americans
are living with alzheimer's disease
of whom two-thirds are elderly women
and it's interesting because there is
protection against near degenerative
disorders for younger women like for
example mitochondria from younger
females
are protected against beta amyloid
toxicity generate less
reactive oxygen species and release less
apoptogenic signals than those
from males however the advantage is lost
in the mitochondria
in older females um which happens with
the onset
of menopause and furthermore a current
alzheimer's treatments only target
acetylcholine and glutamate to treat
symptoms
but not the root cause and since there
seems to be a divergence
um and the discrepancy between the two
genders it's important to figure out
the underlying causes to be able to
better target treatments so first of all
um i'd like to figure out what is going
on as the female ages and if there are
any transfer atomic differences that can
help us identify genes at play and this
which can also help us pinpoint pathways
that
related genes may play a role in in
order to target treatment effectively
next um to talk about female aging for
background information
so menopause is the end of a female's
menstrual
cycle and fertility in which the ovaries
no longer make estrogen and progesterone
and this does not happen just in
humans it happens in most mammals as
well so in this project the data is
collected
from rats and so we will be looking at
the transitioning of menopause in rats
so the first phase
which is both in humans and in rats is
premenopause which is about six months
for the rat
in which they have normal menstrual
cycles and they transition onto
perimenopause at about nine months
in which the cycles become irregular but
they haven't stopped completely
so menopause at about nine months is um
the final starts with the final
menstrual cycle and for humans it would
have stopped for about
a year when we think about human
menopause and then post menopause is at
about 15 months for rats
but this is uh in humans when we hit the
first year mark from
our final menstrual cycle
so from previous studies
as the brain ages in women there's also
an increased
immune response and so we are obtaining
data from this study by mishra at all
in which we have six groups um six
samples each
and this is using rna um sequencing from
the radius norveticus
and female hippocampus and so
we have six groups in which there's a
female rat at six months
and it's abbreviated as reg 6m because
they have a regular
cycle six months then there's nine
months um with the normal menstrual
cycle or reg 9m
um nine months irregular or irregular 9m
magnets acyclic or acyclic 9m
then ovx at 9m which is overrectimized
rats which means that their ovaries have
been removed
and this is significant because and it
acts as a control
because um ovx represents the most
important clinical features of estrogen
deficiency
um induced like a modeling
post-menopausal conditions
um and then there's also the female rat
at 16 months ecyclic menstrual cycle
and so as we continue on i found my
research question and hypothesis
so firstly understanding the genes
expressed differently in the progressive
stages of female aging and menopause
can help us understand risks for near
degeneration and pathways to target in
order to treat near degeneration such as
for alzheimer's disease in women
so a couple of questions that i had um
were how does the age or the time of the
onset of menopause
affect the transcriptomic expression and
which pathways are expressed
are there biomarkers that help us
identify the risk for neurodegenerative
disorders
how does the expression differ in a
rectimized species and regular specimens
and how can that lead to insights in the
onset of neurodegenerative disease
and overall my central question is what
are the effects of the onset of
menopause
on the transcriptomic profile of the
aging female brain
so my hypothesis is twofold firstly i
hypothesize that as the females enter
pre-menopause and perimenopause they
will express less genes related to
neurodegeneration
as the females in menopause and
postmenopause and secondly i
hypothesized that the age and the age of
the onset also had an effect on the
transphobics
of the rats so basically the earlier the
onset of
menopause the more likely they're going
to be expressing uh the
transcriptome for uh for
neurodegenerative
disorders such as alzheimer's disease
which we can compare with those
different groups
so for my methodology i had six groups
to compare
and i will be using principal component
analysis um
differential gene expression analysis
and hierarchical clustering
um uh and i will be using those to
relate expressions to each other's draw
conclusions analyzing
genes are underexpressed which are
overexpressed in six groups and
look at significantly expressed genes
and annotate their function on david and
richard to see the pathways expressed
such as with near inflammation or
near degeneration etc
and for my results first of all i did
preliminary pca between the six groups
and i found that there was a divergence
between the regular groups and then the
groups that were
either irregular or acyclic and so
therefore we then grouped the regular
groups and the acyclic groups and the
irregular groups
and then i did pca and uh
with this is these are the pcie graphs
with all of genes and so between regular
versus acyclic we can see that there are
two groups here and for regular versus
irregular it's not that
they're not two specific groups because
um the components are very small
and they they aren't filtered yet with
only the significant genes
but i went ahead and i did differential
analysis and with the further pca
um so i compared the regular versus the
overcome eyes and i found
that they were significantly different
and so and i also use the significant
genes to make these two pca plots
in which we can see that they're two
discrete groups showing
that there is a very pronounced
difference between the regular and the
irregular and the regular versus
acyclic um and
that even despite the same age there
is a difference in the transcriptome
when it comes to
uh the regular versus the
post-menopausal conditions meaning that
menopause has an effect on the
transatomic
profile so um with differential
expression with further
um i did the volcano plots and i found
these uh significant genes
and also with i've got more plots
um for the regular versus acyclic and
the regular versus
um irregular and
uh it just summarized for what i got
with the significant genes um the
pathways that were upregulated
were the um regular versus if irregular
which is irregular and regular versus
acyclic were
unrelated to immune function and for
down regulation it was related to
oxidative phosphorylation which
is linked to near regeneration and
related to um
mitochondrial dysfunction leading to
near degeneration and
um and they act and for regular versus
irregular and irregular versus acyclic
they actually share
um the for down regulation relate linked
to neurodegenerate higher
neurodegeneration and also
a higher immune response um and for the
hierarchical clustering
when i did the hierarchical clustering i
also my theories were confirmed
um that they were uh that the two groups
were significant
um and so through the pathway analysis
on enricher
um here is the visualization of the
expression of the pathways um in which
over here we could see it related to
immune function and over here
um is for um like increased
neurodegeneration
related to mitochondrial um dysfunction
and oxidative stress
um same thing over here for regular
versus is basically a hydrogen immune
response
and a higher
neurodegeneration linked to
mitochondrial stress
so to conclude for my results um i found
that there
was indeed an impact on the
transformations of the rat um especially
in relation
to the mitochondrial function leading to
the near-degenerative
diseases such as alzheimer's and
parkinson's disease and i also found
that there was a high-density immune
response
um and so this leads to the conclusion
that
in order to that because of the onset of
menopause
this leads to the targeting of possible
treatments for neurodegenerative
diseases
caused by oxidative stress so this has
confirmed that
from this data that menopause
that the onset of menopause somehow has
an effect on the oxidative stress
um causing different neurodegenerative
diseases like alzheimer's disease
and it also supports the chronic
pathology of alzheimer's because um for
alzheimer's the oxidative stress that is
exacerbated damages the
mitochondria which leads to um cell
death
and even more accumulation of beta
amyloid and tau proteins and
neurofibrillary tangles
and in addition uh there
it's something interesting that the
oxidative stress can actually be
um reversed so when there's oxidative
stress the mitochondria structure is
damaged
however um researchers found that when
the accident the cause of the accident
stress is removed the mitochondria
structure bounces back
which could um lead to a possible
treatment
um now for the limitations um certain
limitations is that i was not able to
extract this information myself in the
lab and i had to use data that
other researchers extracted from their
samples so i was not able to control the
sample size
or the procedures used to collect the
data therefore i'm dependent on their
collection strategy
to obtain my results um
and for further research i'd like to if
i uh
was given the opportunity to go into a
lab um i would possibly
uh see how estrogen and progesterone
supplements
um would then affect the transfer
atomics of the rat since um
in menopause the rats are estrogen and
progesterone deficient
and so by testing that that would
confirm my results
and i would also like to see if this is
true in humans as well
so thank you for listening to my
presentation
so thank you all for listening into
natra's presentation as well
uh so dr core do you have anything to
add
or a feedback for netra thank you
i think a good presentation uh there are
some points
there which need improvement i think
i can email her regarding that and that
is regarding
one of the pca plot and the rest of
presentation is i think quite good she's
already completed a lot of things
so some of the issues that she can
address we can actually
ask her so i think rest presentation is
good and here is a question from
emmanuel
splisosome related genes or pathways
were overexpressed any implication
i mean i would just like to add maybe
uh corporate you can answer that in just
a second i just wanted to add to let
everybody know that these two projects
were developed by
high school students who are developing
their research projects to participate
in
life science fairs and competitions so i
think that's
something to keep in mind as we review
these
yeah thank you so much elia dr harpreet
yes you can go ahead
i think uh spliceosome uh maybe there
are the some of the iso forms that are
generated
eventually uh some of iso forms that
affect
uh menstrual cycle maybe the splices on
related genes play an important role
in that case thank you dr hudri
so for the next presentation uh we have
our
intern sonalika ray who will be
presenting on the analysis of
liver cancer transcriptomic data for
drug repurposing
so so narika please go ahead thank you
thank you good evening everybody i am
curry currently i'm pursuing masters in
bioinformatics from punjab university
and i'm interning with pine biotech and
my purpose here
is to complete my desertation project
for masters
my research and trust lies and genomic
data science
and computer aided drug designing so
today i would be giving an overview of
the literature and would discuss the
highlights of my research proposal which
is on the analysis of transcriptomic
data for
drug repurposing so you see hcc is the
most
common form of liver cancer and it is
the third most leading cause of death
worldwide
it has got various risk factors involved
with
it also there are about seven to eight
drugs
which are actually in the market to
treat htc
but it's only the drug soda phenom which
is fda approved in u.s
so soda finance is such a drug which
actually doesn't show its effect in the
later stages of
ecstasy and therefore the scc becomes
surafinib resistance
so scc remains a treatment challenge due
to first of all lead detection
yes because most of the times scc is
detected
very later in the stages and resistance
to currently approved
drugs so the paper which i went through
was the transaptomix based drug
repurposing approach which identifies
noble drugs against surafin and
resistance hepatocellular carcinoma
and the purpose of this paper was to
expediate identification of noble drug
candidates against soda
finance resistant sec so the workflow as
shown here gives an overview of
computational drug
repurposing and drug target network
here in the sr scc that is the sodaphone
resistant
scc cell lines were generated from the
normal scc cell lines
by exposing the normal cell lines to
soraa phenet for a period of time
and then the gene expression signatures
of experimental models of
scc-seraphine resistance were assessed
they were assessed for prognostic
significance
and the queries against gene expression
signatures characterizing drug
perturbation in hebg2 cell line
containing the lynx database now the
lynx is a database that is library of
integrated network based cellular
signature analysis
this links database connect provides us
with the connectivity scores which were
calculated by the rank-based
non-parametric weight calculus smirnoff
statistic
and drugs with negative connectivity
scores
that is anti-correlated represent that
are hypothesized to reverse scc
seraphine resistance
gene signature and the drug candidates
were further prioritized based on fda
approval clinical investigation status
known as antonio plastic activity and
literature evidence for drug target
genes associated with ssc
and then finally two drugs were
subsequently selected
for in retro validation so this is just
a very small representation of what the
workflow actually was so here
two cell lines were taken this first one
was the normal scc cell line and then we
have the solar phenome resistant
scc cell line and then these two cell
lines
were subjected to connectivity mapping
through links database
now connectivity mapping provides with
the connectivity scores which were
calculated by the rank-based
non-parametric weight care statistics
and after the connectivity score
the connectivity mapping the data sets
were taken from tcg and geo to cross
verify with the gene expression data
cells characterizing
scc patient tumors of diverse etiologies
and this is just a look of what the link
tools look like so there
are various tools which are involved
with the links
and i would be reviewing them later in
the presentation itself
so my research question lies to search
for molecules
to search for the molecules which could
actually
be could be used effectively against the
sonophonic resistance
as cc and then i would like to find the
pathways
which which are involved with these
molecules
those pathways which these compounds
actually affect
the drug targets so i have few questions
which i would like to answer while uh
linking the effective compounds against
sr resistance scc
that would be out of all the compounds
which compound could be linked to scc
and whether the predictive compound was
effective and
if it was effective then in which
pathway it was
involved and the approach i would be
following
would be to take the cell line and then
match the gene expression alterations in
resistant ssd with gene expression
changes which are caused by the
treatment of cancer cells
with drugs already fda approved for
other diseases
and then find the drug that can reverse
the resistance related changes
herein approved and investigational drug
drug link files could be downloaded from
drug bank database
and to look for drugs under clinical
investigation we can go through
aacetb database that is aggregate
analysis of clinical trial dot g
dot gov database and then the keg drug
database ids could be
mapped to drugs in drug bank to extract
drug
activity and target pathway and then the
drug target
genes obtained could be assessed with
ssd using the beagle literature mining
tool
so once we have the drugs which could be
used effectively against the
serotonin resistant scc then we could
look or we could identify the mechanism
of action
that is the pathway or the drug target
which is involved
in the scc resistant
solar phenome right and after we are
done with the mechanism
then we could provide proof of concept
evidence for validity of the drug
repurposing approach with potential
for use in the personalized medicine
so now i would just like to explore the
links with you all
and show you how it actually works so
here uh this is the
links tools uh database where a lot a
lot of tools are mentioned so it has a
long list of tools but here
i would be interested in uh the tools
like repurposing apps which could be
used for drug repurposing
drug cell line browser so now this is a
really
nice browser which could be used to uh
actually look for a various drugs and
cell lines
and then a drug pathway browser eye
length so let's just
have a look at eye links so you see this
eye links
uh it helps us to get a list
with of gene signatures so if i go for
the hd2 cell line
then i would actually get a list of gene
signatures
which i could easily download and look
for the genes now in this gene
signatures list i would be getting
scores and probabilities
going to which i could select with genes
i have to
further analyze right and
then i have and then i have uh
another set i'll just give you a second
sorry
yes actually i'm not able to
okay so maybe that was it uh now i would
like to hand over to beep shah thank you
thank you sunadika uh dr
well just before dr harper i i want to
mention that you know this project is
very interesting i think relevant
for anyone who has an interest in drug
repurposing
because what essentially she is doing is
combining
a transcriptomic data set with
fda approved drug signatures on this
links database
and might be an interesting approach for
some of the other people that i know are
a part of this session
who are thinking about different types
of drug repurposing
uh projects of their own
uh so can i add something else as well
actually there was some issue with my
screen now it's fine so i
actually wanted to share this screen and
show like how wonderful this repo
repurposing tool is so if i look for the
drug soda in it and
try to look at the target so let's say i
look for the braf target
and then i could easily take that target
into drug
bank and look for other drug relations
which i could get
so if i look for braf itself i
get an a drug named foster matinum which
could actually be used as a potent drug
again effective for uh the soda finite
resistance cell line
so this way we could actually get a good
um a good list of drugs
and also then the other tool which was a
drug cell line browser
so i could easily download the uh solar
phone a resistance ssd cell line of
deliver from here
and with this download results button i
would actually get an excel sheet of all
the
list of all the cell lines and then i
could
use it further for research thank you
great
thank you so much assanalica for sharing
this uh dr harvey
did you have something to add to this um
hello i think this is nice presentation
and
uh good proposal so i think you can
proceed for the
uh to proceed for this project and uh
there is uh some of the things that you
can also find some other cell lines
maybe
uh that show distance to the
particular surface light right so those
are drugs against you can actually find
some other cell lines also
in literature
in the next part we would be listening
to participants who have joined the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
training and research program now let me
give you
a little bit of a background what this
program was
in january 2021 we launched a six-month
research program in collaboration with
the university of
ghana focused on infectious diseases
this program is organized by dr anita
gansha
who previously completed a research
fellowship
and several different omics logic
programs
after completing an introductory
overview of
bioinformatics methods for infectious
diseases research
we are now planning to follow up
programs on genomics and transcriptomics
so as our participants have completed or
have completed the
infectious disease program many of them
has
research proposals which are ready and
today we are going to be hearing
three such research proposals so for the
first part of this
i would want to invite courage at aboard
to present
on genetic variation studies of sexual
stage
specific antigens pfs 230 lpfs 4845
of plasmodium falciparum population in
africa
and their potential implications on
transmission blocking vaccines
so courage please go ahead and share
your screen
please i cannot share my screen can i
can it be your number
yeah thank you
can the other user stop sharing so that
i can share
hello courage can you go into
presentation mode yeah thank you
so hello my name is carriage adobo
and in this presentation i will provide
a rationale for the project titled
genetic variation studies of social
speech-specific
bfs 230 and bfs 48
plus million for separate populations in
africa
and their potential implications
proposal
has been developed as a part of the
homicide bioinformatics training program
conducted by pine biotech in
collaboration with the nguji
memorial institute for medical research
at
the university of ghana
so i will be collaborating with larite
to do this
project my personal background is in
bioinformatics i have
a bsc in biomedical engineering and i
have been interested
in placing genetics of plasmodium
facilities
larry's background is in veterinary
services and he's interested in
infectious diseases animals
breeding and genomics as the title said
this project will help understand the
implication of genetic variation
on transmission blocking vaccines
against malaria
and this and is being done under the
supervision of dr anita ganza
and the pan biotech team
plasma facility
plasmodium falciparum malaria still
remains the deadliest form of
malaria especially in children under
five
several controlled interventions
including anti-malaria drugs
and vector control measures like dead
nets and insecticides freeze
have been used to prevent the disease
one tool lacking in this arsenal is a
broadly effective malaria vaccine
over the years the malaria parasite life
cycle has been tested and tried out
but they all face the problem of low
efficacy
which studies have shown to be mainly
due to
high genetic variation of circulating
parasites in the
population notable among this vasin
is the currently most advanced malaria
vasin which is the rtss
which targets the liver stage of the
parasite so talking about the life cycle
of
the parasite after the mosquito
comes for a blood meal and then it
inoculates sporozoites
into the human host so this porosity
travels to the liver and infect the
hepatocytes
and then the the infected hepatocyte
multiplies the
parasites and then further merozoites
are released
into the bloodstream which goes to
infect red blood cells
this infected red blood cells merozoites
after some time some of them mature into
gametes
and these garments are picked up
by mosquitoes when they come for another
blood meal so the rtss vaccine which
targets
the liver stage has has shown
has also shown low efficacy of about 90
of of about 39 against chemical malaria
which was mainly due to the high genetic
variation in circulating parasites as
shown by some
studies some studies have also explored
the potential of
advancing targets that can block the
transmission of gametocytes from the
human host to mosquitoes
which can further block the
fertilization and health reproduction
of this gamete two antigens pfs230
and pfs-48 which are expressed on the
surface of gametocyte
have been shown to elicit strong
antibody responses
against plasmodium falciparum however
the problem of genetic variation which
plagues the
other vaseline candidates have not been
fully
explored within these two
antigens in the african parasite
population
so the problem for the problem
the efficacy of current malaria
vaccine candidates are hindered due to
the diverse nature of
their target antigens successful
transmission blocking vaccine
would induce immune responses against
the malaria parasites gametocyte sexual
stages
however the genetic variation of
transmission blocking vaccine antigens
have not been fully
explored in the african parasite
population
so there is the need to explore the
genetic
variation of transmission blocking
antigen
to further estimate the potential
implication
on transmission blocking malaria
vaccines in
the african parasite population
so our approach is to call single
nucleotide polymorphism from raw data
analyze the functional effect of these
sniffs and further analyze the effect of
these polymorphisms on
epitopes and then evaluate the
population structure
and differentiation within africa
so we'll be taking our data from malaria
gene
the approach in detail is splitted into
three parts so we have
the processing the analysis and
the structure and function for
processing we will take raw
sequence data run the data through
quality checks
perform multiple sequence alignment with
the
sequence call very
that specifically sniffs on the align
sequences
leaves in the genes of interest from the
variant data
and further explore these genes and then
look at how this
how they differentiate
in the african populations then
look at the functional effects of the
snakes when translated to
amino acid for structure and function we
will look at the effect of these snips
unknown
and potential epitopes
and finally do three
3d structure analysis on the wild and
newton's
structures
so about this asset
we will take the community projects in
malaya gym
specifically the raw reads sequences
which are saved
in the european nucleotide archive
database
this data contains 833 samples
from eight african countries and 17
sample sites these samples were
collected between 2014
and in 2015.
so when we the graph shows the
difference the distribution of samples
per country
and as you can see some countries have a
lot of samples
that will employ statistics to help cut
down their samples
to an acceptable number which will not
affect our analysis federal
and this now just tells us
that data this is a snapshot from the
data table which
shows the metadata associated with each
sample
okay also we will
take we'll retrieve the 3d structures
from protein
data bank
with population with populations grouped
into west africa
central africa and east africa
this table shows us the overall derived
allele frequency of snips
within pfs 230 and pfs4
48.45 in general there is more diversity
in pfs-230 but this diversity
is not all it's not in all the regions
of this antigen
there are some regions that are
conserved so we want to understand which
regions are actually impacting
the interaction of these antigens with
antibodies
so when looking at the entire
genome of plasma facility in sub-saharan
africa
this image uses the prevalence and
subgrouping of the various population
of particular interests is
where we see how the various populations
are differentiated
when looking at the entire genome here
we see
how the ghanaian population which is in
light green
is differentiated from other populations
like
syria which is in red and gambia
in green so it will be interesting to
see how these differentiations might be
looking
at this project's antigens that is the
pfs
230 and pfs 4845
so yeah we see the 3d models
from pdb for the two antigens that we'll
be
working with and how they interact with
antibodies we can see in we can see the
antigens colored in yellow
and the antibodies colored
it will be interesting to see how these
interactions
are disrupted by the introduction of the
various mutations that
we will identify in this project
okay so the impact of this project
will be the effectiveness of
transmission blocking malaria vaccines
in africa and whether the development of
cocktail malaria vaccine might be
a better alternative to single epitope
or single antigen
fasting
thank you
thank you so much courage for this
wonderful presentation
i would now like to ask dr herbert to
share
a few words about this dr herbert
hello courage i think very nice
presentation
and a very good research question that
you have
so i have one question as uh
in your first second slide you have uh
you are mentioning that the previous
antigens
the vaccine against the previous dentist
and have a diverse
nature so in comparison to those
antigens
so can you uh let me know exactly what
is the size of these antigen and
how these antisenses actually become a
very specific in comparison to the
previous anticipate least which vaccines
are available
please repeat the question okay
so as in your first slide
you were mentioning that uh that it must
be the second slide i guess
so you were mentioning that there are uh
uh
previously the vaccines are available
against uh
different antigens that have very
diverse nature
yeah right so in comparison to the
those antigens so how these
uh these two antigens we produce
uh either have a more specific nature
whether that uh decide by its size
or exactly but it is the characteristics
that make them
more specific okay
uh i don't quite understand
your question but um
okay let me let me rephrase the question
the
question
is uh sorry courage courage the question
you are mentioning that there is
a uh specificity so less genetic
diversity
for these antigens than the current
vaccine right
you mentioned the current vaccine is
affected by genetic diversity
what about these antigens what makes
them more specific
okay so these antigens are now
being studied steady but genetic
variation has not
been fully explored in them so i cannot
speak to that
after until after the study i don't know
whether i answered the question
right i think what you're trying to say
is that
there could be some genetic diversity as
well but one of the slides he showed the
data
and it shows that at least one of the
antigens looks like has
a much slower allele frequency
than the other one but that's one of the
objectives for him to
actually analyze whether the diversity
is there and whether the diversity is
specific
to different regions and different
countries and what could that mean
for the effectiveness of a vaccine that
would be focused on transmission
yeah yeah okay so
have any idea about size of uh in terms
of amino acid or nucleotide i mean how
long
these antigens
okay so uh yeah
i haven't no no
uh i haven't have an idea of how long
again
am i i know i think that is sometimes
what is the i mean
uh in some of the cases i'm not saying
that every case
if the size of a particular anti-zone or
epitope is small that is
that become more specific maybe that is
the point maybe
you can consider it like if you look at
their size in comparison to the previous
antigens against which
vaccines are available right
okay okay i think very very good
presentation
okay
thank you so much courage and thank you
dr core and elia for your feedback
next up we have elliplane m akashi
who is going to present on understanding
interactions
between malaria vaccine candidates and
other proteins to inform more
effacious vaccine designs
eli you can go ahead and present thank
you
hello good afternoon everyone
and can you hear me yes we can hear you
and also see your screen can you go into
presentation mode please
okay um i'll be presenting
on a project proposal and that
understanding interactions between
malayan candidates
and other proteins to inform more
efficacious russian design
and the work is being done
by a team from the niguchi memorial
institute of medical research
at the university of ghana and
one of the team members the team members
as follows dr benedict
mensah and myself
and our principal investigator is doctor
tagansa
and this is work is done in
collaboration with the pine biotech team
and the team is interested in the
population genetics of
malaria vasant candidate antigens
so um like my colleague
um presented and yeah malaria
is still a major public health
importance especially
in sub-saharan africa
in which ghana is part and so far
there's been
efforts to control malaria which is the
use of insecticide
mosquito sprays and then drugs but then
those
efforts are being hindered by issues of
drug resistance and insecticide
resistance so therefore we need
um it's about time we get a vason but we
need a broadly effective vessel
against the various diverse strains we
of p p4c paramalayal strength we have in
our population
um over the years antigens expressed
at the various stages of the p false
parent life cycle has been targeted for
vascular development and the
p fossil from life cycle when a mosquito
takes a blood meal it
injects what we call sporazoid into the
bloodstream
and those projects move from
the bloodstream and infect the liver
cells and the process continues to
infect red blood cells
and then develop into merozoites
gametocytes and then the cycle continues
again and however the most
this is investment antigens have been
grouped into three major categories
we have the transmission blocking
vessels we have the anti-infection
vessels
and we have the blood stage vessels
however the most advanced
currently is their lts as aso1 vasin
which has been designed based on um
plasmodium falciparum sequence project
protein
and this protein is expressed um on the
surface of spirozoid and
and it inhibits um sporozoites motility
and invasion of hepatocytes another
antigen of interest in our study that
we'll be looking at
is pfami1 which is um
a transmembrane protein that is
localized in the microphones
of merizoid and is released during
and in invasion of red blood cells
and this categorizes um characterizes
the
disease stage of p false apparent
um this study um
was conducted and there's a it's in two
parts and
the first part was looking at genetic
diversity of
two major um vason candidate
antigens which is the pfcsb and then the
pfama1
which is epical membrane antigen one
and we looked at this um antigens
in ghana and at for
in three different ecological zones and
for malaria control purposes
and malaria control purposes
ghana has been divided into three major
economic
epidemiological zones we have the guinea
shuk
northern strogini savannah we have the
forest built and then the coastal
savannah zones
and transmission in the guinea savannah
is high
and then transmission is known to be
high during the rain and seasons
and very low um during the dry seasons
another measure to characterize malaria
prevalence of high malaria transmission
is the number of infective bites from
the mosquito per year
and is it's called entomological
inoculation rate
and we gathered that in the northern
savannah zones we have
um 418 effective bites per year
in the forest zones we have 866 and in
the coastal zones we have about 50
infected bites per year
um so like i said these two
um antigens which is the circumsporozoid
and then the ama1
are antigens of interest we are looking
at um the second protozoa
protein we are looking at the diversity
of this protein in ghana
because um the the wasan
currently has been designed based on a
lab strain
of of plasmodium falciparum
not taking into consideration the
multiple strains we have in our
population
and the lts has has been designed
based on part of the central repeat
region
which is the image on the right and then
um
the polymorphic t-cell epitope and has
been fused with an
um hepatitis b antigen to boost immunity
and then studies have shown that the cd4
epitopes
are very polymorphic but then those
epitopes are also very important enemy
and
mediated cell
cell mediated t cell immune responses
also for ama1 we
looking at the different domains and
then how polymorphic those domains are
in order to ascertain whether we can use
those verses and those
antigens to to build and a vason as well
so um hypothetically um we we say that
malaria transmission plays a major role
in diversity and potentially the
efficacy this diversity could impact how
efficacious
and existent and busses might be in a
natural parasite population
so area studies
conducted on pfcsp in our lab we found
out that especially at the sea terminal
regions
we found out that we have a lot of
haplotypes
um in which are shown in different
colors
on the bar plots and their frequencies
as well
sorry so um
we looked at two different ecological
sites as i mentioned earlier we looked
at cape coast which is located
in the coastal belt and we looked at
navrongo which is in the
northern belt to kind of ascertain
whether echo epidemiological factors
affect the rate of diversity
and we thought that um more
more um diversity was seen in cape
in avonga than in cape coast also we
looked at
specific epitope regions like i said the
t-cell epitomes and we looked at
what kind of amino acids are being
put what kind of mutations are being
presented in these epitomes and how
conserved are they or how frequent are
they
we also did the same analysis for the
pfama one looking at two different
epitomes background
and cape coast so with all this um
epitopes or with all those variations
that we've seen
we want to go ahead and
look at how it affects structural
interactions and function specifically
we've already
ascertained variations in pfcsp and pfa
me1 in ghana
and what we want to do now is predict
the impact of
these variations in the form of amino
acid changes
in specific epitope regions in immune
epitope regions
upon the proton structure interactions
and functions
and for the pfcsp we are looking at
mutations at
the t-cell epitopes of the pfcsb and how
they affect
binding to t cells for the pfc
ama1 we are looking at um structural
interactions between
this gene and then another proton called
pf
run two one two means plasmodium
falciparum rope treat
will keep protein two and these two
proteins
um form moving junctions
um at the external membranes of
mirazoid to be able to eva invade
the um whole cells erythrocytes so we
want to see
if diversity of ama1
can affect binding of pie everyone too
and and how this binding would affect
entry into wholesale um
post eritrea sites and
some studies have been conducted and
then we know the structure of pfama1
and furthermore we want to ascertain if
um the binding um poses some kind of
structural confirmation
conformational changes um between
um the wild type which in our case we
are looking at the pre
f3d7 as our reference string and then
the various diverse strings we found in
our population
when we have hydrophobic and
conformation
or are we going to see the same
hydrophobic conformations when we bind
the rope
round two that are varying strains in
our population
two ama1 and once also do that
for pfcsp and its interactions with t
cells as well so the first part of our
objectives
um is almost done we have aligned
um amino acid sequences and we have done
some population genetic analysis we've
done
some genetic diversity industries where
we looked at nucleotide diversity
haplotype formations we look at
hypothesized diversities
we look at special variations between
our two or three sites
in the ghanian population and we also
did some pca analysis
we also looked at the patterns of a
minor acid frequent substitution
and you want to employ those employ the
same method
to look at other african populations
and also populations from thailand so
this
objective um outline will be um
used in other african populations as
well
zoning on to the second objective which
is prediction of impact of a minor asset
change in the immune epitopes of
phosphorylation structure
we will first go ahead to predict and
model three-dimensional structures of
our variants
and then also predict how they bind
especially let's say the pfami and how
it binds to pf12
and also the pfcsp and how it binds to c
and t cells and we'll also see
if the predictions or the potential
impacts of the substitutions
on the structure or function
and so in ghana we look we have
220 samples and
earlier on we looked at economy
epidemiological differences so
in narongo we had 128 samples in clip
because we had what 92.
and we want to employ malawi
and kenya for pfcsp because those two
countries
are also um undergoing phase four
rts clinical trials so we want to see if
we are going to get the same
results in these two countries and for
pfa ma1
aelia studies in ghana incorporated 331
samples and we had
150 for background and 181 for cape
coast
we also want to look um do the same
analysis
um in mali kenya and thailand
our data type is first a sequences and
this data was generated
in in our lab at meguchi
overall the implication of this study is
that it will add on new information
regarding the anti-genetic diversity of
these two major antigens
that we are talking about and this will
help us
and what kind of um
haplotypes to include in investment
design whether we need a chimeric
version
that will be including the most popular
and the most frequent
antigens and also it will help us
know if um antibodies or
teeth or mediated um immunity
will affect those vibrations the same
way or not
thank you very much
thank you so much eli uh dr harpreet
please go ahead and share your thoughts
on her presentation
hello ellie i think it's a nice
presentation and
you have already addressed the
population that you are considering i
think it is very good project
and you can proceed for this yeah
okay thank you
okay thank you so much dr harpreet and
eli
so the next presentation is by
rita boateng who will be presenting on
understanding mechanisms
underlying host immune responses to
severe source cove to infections in
malaria
endemic regions over to utah
hello good evening everybody um my name
is rita
and i'll be presenting on understanding
and
mechanisms underlining hosts immune
responses
to severe sask of two infections in
malaria endemic region
and this project is a team project
so for the team i'll be working with
emphasis
who is currently has finished
his msc in human genetics and i'm
also currently a phd student working on
structure
and structural analysis and
computational biology and for our team
we will be supervised by our pi which is
um dr
anita and also from the pine
group hi rita can you make your
screen in a presentation mode thank you
please can you see
oh we still see your slides all of them
yeah as courage is writing switch your
display
okay i've done that can you please see
ah no we just see all of your slides i
think you can
continue so i'm not able to do this it's
okay all right please continue
okay sorry for that okay so for my team
i'll be working with this group of
people to make the project successful
um so as we already know malaria over
the years
is characterized by high incidence of
the disease
basically or muslims you're still on
your first slide
rita if you are using two displays then
you have to
show the one on which you are projecting
your slides
um i'm not using two displays
please is there any difference
we can see your uh slides okay francis
says that
he can share his previous friends as you
can please over here
i will just make you co-host give me one
moment
like
so i think when you share you share your
screen itself
not the slide not the powerpoint
presentation
so that if you project will see the
screen itself
because if you share only the powerpoint
sometimes it might show that
non-projectors like
yeah but i think at this point you know
maybe just
oh okay great there we go can you see
yes thank you so much
okay thank you um so um my name is rita
afria bharti and i'll be
presenting on my team on
with my team which is on the topic i'm
understanding
mechanisms underlining host immune
responses
to severe susceptible infections in the
malaria endemic region
so this project is done in the team and
my team i'll be present i'll be
doing this project with francis and then
also be supervised
by um dr anita
and also the pine group
so as already said malaria over the
years is characterized by
high incidence in in of the disease
in africa however with the emergence of
um coveted 19 m cases which was
is caused by the sus covey 2 we could
see
um a different trend so
um the spread of the disease
um is people are said is considered less
than
like what we expected
okay so what we see is that um
even though we know that malaria is
endemic in africa
and as we could ex we were expecting
that
the emergence of covet 19 could have
some severe effect in africa
but then we are seeing otherwise and
then
we see that the high proportion of um
these enzyme traumatic
cases and in malaria endemic regions
as compared to other parts of the world
and the major
findings have uh postulated that these
major differences with them
saskatchewan infections are across
malaria endemic
regions and also non-endemic regions
is as a result of the severe stage of
the saskof2
infection um this severe stages of the
sarcopte infection is described by
various distinct immune and horse
responses
such as the inflammatory and cytokines
release
and an example is the hyperinflammation
and conditions
and also cytokine and stones which
actually provoke severe lung and
alterations that can lead to
multi-organ failure
an example is the
pre-existing malaria infections could
actually be
a factor to observe the level of severe
infections and severe susceptibility
to infections an example to show is the
low number of the severe cases
in sub-saharan africa which have some
research have postulated is
as the reason why there is variable
distribution genes such as the ace 1 and
d
and also the ac e2 polymorphisms
and them which have been reported to
partly explain the
observed and clinical heterogeneity that
we are seeing across
endemic and non-endemic regions
so from this it is important that as
researchers we should be able to
investigate
some of the underlying mechanism of
factors that are contributing to this
and looking at the host immune responses
to this phenomenon
so for our study we we hypothesized that
um this observed low reported case of
severe susceptibility to infections that
we see
and could be attributed to the high
exposure of malaria infections
um in malaria endemic regions
and they adapted and host immune
responses
and to malaria and for this study our
main aim is to investigate
and transcriptional and signatures and
the molecular pathways involving
in malaria and and severe starts
covered 19 infections
so for the project our objective
first objective is to compare and
irony transitional profiles of the
various stages of malaria
and also the sask of two infections and
we'll be looking at
the adult population and also to perform
some functional annotations of
differential gene x expressions
so for our the outline of our
method our method is um consists of five
main steps first we select
um the data then
them as defined by defined and the
disease
phases of interest that i've already
said and the second
we will clean the data and put the
required formats
for downstream analysis and for this
method we will make good use of the the
pine
um path um pipeline
to perform this sum of this analysis
and so thirdly we will perform rna-seq
analysis
by leveraging the pipeline that we
developed
and then fourthly we would perform
element-based analysis
which will include factor analysis
um and also regression analysis
and also and we will also perform some
pca and clustering
and other statistical analysis then
we will then perform functional
annotation
and analysis leveraging
and the pipeline and also some important
um
annotation databases um
available so for our data set for this
project
we have this asset of um transcriptome
and data set for
covet 19 severe carbon 19 infections
which is one
and this dataset set um
consists of expression profiles from
um high protrudes and sequencing and our
second
data which will be a comparative one for
the stars covered an infection is the
the data for malaria and for this we
select the acute um the conversant and
also the peak
of the infections
so just to show you what actually
is in this data so for the acute
malaria section we have a total of 25
and samples and for there we have the
acute
[Music]
acute infection of the malaria which we
have 10
and then the conversant stage which we
have and 10
and also the peak infection stage which
we have
five and also for covet 19 we have the
remission stage which is the sage that
there is a decrease in or
at this appearance of the signs and
symptoms of the covet
and although covet might be present so
the factor of asymptomatic is also
present
then also we have um a place where there
is no remission
and for this we have a total of 125
samples and with 116 for emission and 9
for for no remission
so for our steady implication we
we would like to see at the end of the
project
to elucidate the underlay some of the
underlying mechanisms of cvs of two
and immune responses in malaria endemic
regions and also from the analysis
we also wish to look at some
significantly expressed genes which
could be very good targets for coveted
19 treatments being its
um personal development or nobel drug
targets
and thank you very much and we
we are ready for any question if there
is
thank you so much rita uh elia or dr
herbert if you would want to share
something thank you
i mean i just want to ask this sounds
like a very interesting study
but have you thought of a control so for
example
ghana is or africa is one of those
regions with malaria but also you have
some
asian countries or you have maybe south
american countries that have
a lot of malaria is it the same there
have you seen the same trend of
infections there
um okay thank you for the question i
think so far we've not thought about
that line but i think it's it's very
good question and we will consider that
for our next presentation looking at the
control
great thank you
so thank you rita for presenting again
and
all of the participants in our
infectious disease program thank you
again
for sharing your presentations and your
projects with the group here
i wanted to focus on some very
interesting uh topic regarding
africa so we have been organizing omix
logic training program in africa
since 2020 and now we have a dedicated
team that serves hundreds of students
across various countries in africa
so as you see in my screen these are
some of the data that we have from the
different programs
we did in africa so we have had over
different number of participants in all
of these programs so these are some of
the programs that we have done
with the participants there and numbers
who have joined these sessions here you
see the countries
in africa from where we have the most
number of our participants joining us
from
so which is also interesting to watch as
all of these participants continue to
collaborate with each other they
continue to learn together and
here is an interesting insight but that
we
learned from our participants background
so
this pie chart shows you the different
numbers of
undergraduate graduates post graduates
phds as well as
industry experts that we have among all
the participants who take part in the
somix logic programs
and also how many of them are saying
whether they would be recommending the
program to others
so we have had about 98 of these
participants who say that yes they would
definitely want to recommend
the omix logic training programs to
their friends or their peers
and i also wanted to take this moment to
introduce you to the omics logic nigeria
team
so this team is being led by adekunde
he is the omex logic nigeria program
lead
and also faculty at leed city university
in nigeria
along with him we have adida bodhisatte
he is also a faculty at biro university
and the omix logic community manager for
africa so in the chat box i would also
be posting
the email id for aditayo
and the africa team which is africa at
pine dot bio
if you all want to reach out to them
for any kind of questions relating to
the omics logic training programs
in nigeria and africa and we also have
sani hamza who is a medical laboratory
scientist
and together they have been running and
conducting these omits logic programs in
africa they are completely trained and
they
also organize their own sessions so
please feel free to reach out to them
regarding any kind of basic or
specialized training that you are
interested in
and now i would like to invite some of
our participants who are part of these
omics logic training
in africa to talk more about
their experience in this omits logic
program
so firstly i would like to invite
oceaninka damilola to share
the presentation with us over to you da
malola
good evening
i wish you my screen thank you
pizza
okay please can you hear my screen
yes we can see your screen now yes okay
hello good evening everyone i'm daniel
schramko graduate of physiology from the
university of lagos nigeria
i'm here to present a review about my
journey those from
biotech's missouri program africa
a program which i actually first did
about two months ago
so um firstly i would like to
give a brief background about myself and
what prompted me to join the program
so i said like i said my name is ashwin
kadam lola and i graduated from the
college of medicine university of lagos
nigeria in 2019
where i majored in physiology and
currently i'm
an ox logic training participant and my
core interest lies in drug
discovery right from junior high i've
always loved calculations
but the higher curiosity drove my
interest to media and physiology in
college
see i knew next to nothing about the
human body and i was determined to
satisfy my curiosity believe me
i did furthermore in physiology
i understood the mechanisms behind
several pathologies
and my next goal after completing my
bachelors
was was an is to understand the steps
that have been taken
or are currently undertaking to cure
these diseases
so perusing the internet on a starting
day i discovered that bioinformatics was
just the perfect discipline
that inculcates several disciplines
amongst which are my favorites
maths and biology to answer questions
about the mechanisms
that drive population diversities
especially in terms of resistance to
medication as well as the genetic
or phenotypic characteristics that
actually cause
these variations
progressing with the course my
scientific goals are somewhat modified
that is to drive prescriptive
medications from a one-size-fits-all
to personalize medicine based on genetic
profile and transcriptomic
expressions why because the robustness
of our body's interaction
networks leaves room for the formation
of alternative natural groups
with the same disease expressions in
different individuals
take for example the triple negative and
the illuminati breast cancer
also i refined this goal because
so much research is going to developing
new drugs every year and
more than 20 percent fail at clinical
trials so there is
i figure there is much more need for
targeted approach towards
drug development overall fine biotech's
training program has taken me several
steps closer to my goals
and these are some of the notable
takeaways from the lessons and sessions
i've learned about the basics of
genomics transdominics
the crucial role the microbiome plays in
regulating our body functions
and in determining the efficacy of
medications we
ingest i also learned to use our python
programming tools to read and visualize
data
that is the sequenced reads in the
coding number program
notably i understood the role of
bioinformatics in biomarker analysis
for effective diagnosis i understood the
classification of diseases into
subgroups
for personalized therapy using machine
learning tools like principal component
analysis
moreover i understood that allelic
variants and mutations play a major role
in population diversity
and actually determine drug application
in individuals
for instance where you have a
pharmaceutical company reduce a drug and
have clinical trials
some subjects don't respond to the
treatment because of a nonsense mutation
that prevents the
formation of cytochrome enzymes and so
pro drugs can be converted to active
drugs
furthermore using the variant coding
pipeline to detect
single nucleotide polymorphisms a
picture of which you can see
by the right side of the slide i was
able to determine if
and which variants actually cause
pathological defects in
mutated cells so these are some of the
training parts of truth and the
pipelines i run
around rna sequence pipeline with
pre-arranged algorithms
such as bow tie 2g to map on reference
genome
calculated the abundance of breeds using
our same
i used quantum normalization to remove
their expression levels
and to convert rates to logarithmic
scale for further analysis
using more machining algorithms like pcm
going forward these are the areas i
intend to pursue
such as identifying biomarkers based on
classification of gene expressions
within a disease type and running
simulations of molecular docking
techniques
and exploring how prototype drugs
interact with
proteins to block signaling batteries
some of the scientific questions i'm
interested in answering using
bioinformatics skill set
are what are the mechanisms or
characteristics that drive population
diversity
especially in terms of our body systems
does our daily interaction have effect
on our genetic expressions over time
how can we use the study of red genetic
afflictions to gain
pioneer insights into prevalent diseases
so the first question that i actually
had
answered was during the sessions i've
been able to
actually get answers to this when dr
aditya talked about
smps and even from the metagenomics
course i
took on the tbi platform i was able to
see that even the human microbiome
actually drive population diversity
the tt bio courses are so well
structured that participants can run
demo pipelines solely on the steps
listed
but of course during the program i had
awesome mentors who took their time even
at orders to explain difficult concepts
mentors like the detail mr dickley mr
sunny amongst others
i mean you'd be hard-pressed to find
support like that in other
bioinformatics programs
i must say that this program has led a
really solid foundation
has laid a really solid foundation for
me to run
bioinformatics makeup research projects
confidently and i look forward to
continuing the team to reach the next
milestones on the program
many thanks to my co-participants we
made the phone and thanks also to the
coordinators both on the national level
and the international level
thank you very much listening to my
presentation
thank you so much for the wonderful
presentation we wish you all the best
so for the next participant is zainab
who is also going to be sharing about
the experience of the omics logic
program suzanna
over to you
hello good evening everyone
please can you show my slide
[Music]
okay
hello good evening everyone and today
i'm going to be presenting
about my steps to bioinformatics through
budget in nigeria fine biotech
my name is zainab and
um my name is inaudible i'm an
undergraduate student of the project
university of lagos
currently studying pharmacology and also
a participant of the basic corn and
mixed logic training
i'm passionate about computational
biology and drug development
my scientific goal for participating in
this
program is to be able to incorporate
data science and machine learning
into science and health care and my
research brought me to a field called
bioinformatics and computational biology
my participating in this program are
taking a step towards my career but
which is to become a drug developer and
this program has tutorial getting me on
ground i'm going to started with
bioinformatics
like the brilliant news from the session
the
trainee is packed with a lot of
good courses like introduction to
bioinformatics with transcriptomizing
genomics
basically of thoughts bioinformatics
it's basically genomics for and getting
on starting the program next to makeup
bar information percentage and
also the code the python and the
algorithm language
is user-friendly and can be easily
navigated
by a participant also
i was able to and are and understand how
it's being used in bioinformatics
i also learned different formats into
which biological data can be presented
that's the samples and the bam files and
also the different repository where you
can get
your data if you have your personal
projects you want to
carry out my area of interest going
forward i have interest in
computer-aided drug discovery drug
development and computational
biology i'm presently watching and
in order to see whether an activity
that can be incorporated into the
discovery of hiv
or copuit910
one question i would love to serve using
bioinformatics
is the incorporation of an african
genome into the drug development
i mostly found out through research that
africans are not being
um africans are not being
and never been inclusive that's uh in
the recent times recognizing
vaccine brought to south africa there
was a complaint about
side effects and all
and i'm going to advise anyone who
hasn't registered for this program too
please do so it's very eye-opening
and it's a very good program to get you
started you really don't have to be in
the science field
you can be in any field and the program
is like
bioinformatics is very diverse and can
be incorporated into any
shoe they like thank you very much all
for listening
thank you so much enough for sharing
this and
next we have uh dr
nancy
share her feedback with us over to you
dr
nancy
hello everyone can you see my screen
yes we can see your screen thank you
okay my name is
i'm a veterinarian by profession and i
lecture
with the federal university of
agriculture macquarie in nigeria
my specialty is actually in veterinary
public health and preventive medicine
i was one of the participant
participants during the
recently concluded basic logic 1
training my research opened this
point it's on zoonotic parasite
trying to understand the epidemiology
and recently i jumped into genomics
characterizing the parasite that i
worked on that was
that's on toxo toxoplasma gondii
it's been a long passion for me since my
dbm days
up to this moment working on happy
complex and parasites
my research interest is is a molecular
is on molecular epidemiology of
infectious genetic diseases and in food
safety now how did i get into omics
logic
i got this information from a telegram
group i
belong to the nigerian bioinformatics
and genomics
telegram group um because of the play i
had
for bioinformatics i it prompted me
to imprompted me to go in further i
actually wanted to do bioinformatics at
a master's level but
i had no mentor at that point on
what it was all about and how to go
about it
in fact a senior colleague i act told me
that you
you get to just sit down on a chair and
you keep computing and typing and all
that
so because of that i didn't push you you
know i didn't go further
but this opportunity came and because of
my flair for computing statistics
matters i went in for it so far i've
been able to do some of the courses
this is my progress level for now though
i have lots of work i
try to create time to do this so i've
been able to do some of the courses
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
introduction to genomics
metagenomics and also very interestingly
that i love
so much is the coding section i've been
trying to learn how to
uh program using r and python
and so this platform gives you the basic
on how to um to use r
in you know in solving um
data or information so it was very
interesting and very simplified for me
so my scientific goals for participating
in this program was want to learn about
bioinformatics remember i had a flat for
it
then to understand or mix data and how
to interpret it when i see it and pair
with the journals
you know when sometimes when you look at
this paper you see it's so technical
that you can't even understand
what's what's talking about but now
after going through the first
program i could stick down digest the
paper and follow into this logical
conclusion to a certain extent because
of the basics i
understand i gained you know
getting involved in the program again i
also wanted to apply bioinformatics to
my aerospace organization which is
veterinary public health
you know marry it into epidemiology of
zoonotic infectious diseases
and then identify a problem within this
context and solve a research
problem using omix data and its analysis
too
now going um being involved in this
program
where i was exposed to
a real-time real-life cloud-based server
the t-bio info platform where we run
pipelines analyzing comics data
we worked on a variant calling
you know we had to go through the
various process we had the pre-process
maps using bow tie two and then these
differential variant calling using
striker
then entered the pipeline and then we
visualized our
results we visualized the the the result
on
igb so it was actually an eye opener i
would
you know understand the process and make
sense make meaning out of it again i
i was also exposed to loading and
visualizing of data in arab python
and understood the basic concepts of
this of the omics bioinformatics
genomics
metagenomics epigenomics transcriptomics
and then
analysis of new generator next
generation sequence
data my area of interest going forward
i want to apply bioinformatics to
um epidemiology of infectious genetic
diseases
how do i use this knowledge you know
in understanding the epidemiology of
this disease
is anything at a gene level that
actually predisposes
a particular group of animals with
particular disease even
among the disease group across various
age groups sex book is there anything
about
at the gene level that makes them being
predisposed
this is what i want to look into in
future
i would like to want to also answer
relationships between general types of
parasites of interest
and autogenicity for example toxoplasma
gondii which i worked on during my phd
it's it's studies have shown that
particular genotypes
of the parasites are more pathogenic
than the other
and so i want to look at this
relationship and then
in the nigerian context in the nigerian
population and also check evolutionary
relationship between parasites within
nigeria and africa as well and that's
obtained elsewhere in the world i also
want to explore
um the hospital relationship it's going
to be a new
area for me because i've not actually
done so much about this but i'm open to
it
because going through this program has
actually opened my eyes and listening to
the wonderful projects here
i mean it's it's really an eye opening
opportunity so the unique advantage with
this
program and why i recommend it is that
first
as someone who do not have any basic
knowledge at all
of bioinformatics you are able to
understand the basic concepts of
molecular biology and bioinformatics
and also the group also the program and
the platform also create
gave great mentorship and support to to
the participants for example i had a
situation where
a daytime was with me till past 11
trying to take me through
that's past 11 in the night trying to
take me through
how to visualize the genome using the
igb browser
i mean it was interesting and surprising
that i kept getting on at that time and
i had
my baby by my side but we went through
it and i got it done
so the mentorship was the support was
wonderful
and then they have well-designed courses
with great content
yes i give it i give to this program
they have great content
and then you are able to assess your
the knowledge you have gained so far by
the quizzes
the design of the quizzes in fact in
some situation i was sweating
answering some of those questions and my
blood pressure was high because i wanted
to
you know get the 80 um
pass mark so it was quite interesting
and more importantly there were
handsome practice with the tbio platform
now
with the t by seven if you ask me the
next level
for this program should be a degree
awarding program
because having going having gone through
these stages
i think the leaders and administrators
of this wonderful
and program should be thinking towards
the direction of
participants actually getting a degree
after going through
this stream and i want to say thank you
to um hi uh to the omixlogic nigeria
team and to pine biotech for this
wonderful opportunity and i intend to
move forward for that it's uh um with
the course thank you very much
for having me thank you so much uh dr
zulu for sharing such a wonderful
feedback with us
and your experience it's wonderful to
hear from you
we also know that you have been very
actively participating in all the
sessions
and understandable with all the work
that you have so thank you again
for participating and now the session is
open for all
questions i again want to thank all of
our presenters today who took the time
to prepare this presentation and have
been working on these several projects
several different programs so please
ask any questions that you may have
and you can continue to post those
questions uh right here
in the chat box
and also if you all want to be part of
similar programs like this
as i'm not hearing any questions i would
be introducing you to some of the
upcoming programs that we are having
and also as we are going forward let me
also introduce you to
our groups in linkedin and facebook
so these are the groups uh that we have
for all of our participants or even
those who are not part of our training
program but would love to be members of
our community we have these two groups
in facebook and linkedin that you are
welcome to join
and here are the upcoming programs so
for the first program we have a training
which is starting this friday
on omics logic genomics so this program
is again part of the six month
training program that i had mentioned in
collaboration with noguchi memorial
research institute at the university of
ghana
so as i mentioned earlier that we would
be having uh the for phase two genomics
and then
transcriptomics so the first part is the
genomics program which is starting this
friday
which is march 12th and the time is 3
pm gmt you can convert that to your
own local time zone and this would be a
one month training program
which is open to every participant who
is interested in learning about genomic
data analysis
so please feel free to ask us regarding
the training program and i will also be
sharing the link
on this program very shortly
and the next program that we have which
is starting on march
15th is bioinformatics for precision
oncology
so this is again a one month program
on precision oncology or for cancer
research
so this program will start on march 15
which is next week
and here again anybody with an interest
in cancer research can join and take
part
in this training program so let me also
share with you
some of the links to this different
program
okay so let us first start with amit's
logic genomics
and thank you elia for sharing the links
again
so this is the link to pre-register for
the program so once you're
pre-registered
you will receive details regarding the
program we do not have
a lot of time as you see we are starting
on friday
and yet regarding
this so this is the precision oncology
program
so please feel free to review these
programs and if you have
any questions please reach out to us
for participants who would require
scholarships
please you can also write to us
regarding this at marketing at
fine dot bio regarding any of the
programs that you are
attending and the scholarships that you
would be requesting
the only thing that we want to mention
here
for anybody who is applying for a
scholarship is that
we would need to meet with you and one
of your references
if you have to give you the scholarship
for the programs
and during the meeting we will walk you
through
the different steps processes and also
introduce
your reference to this opportunity and
based upon that meeting whether you
receive a scholarship or not
is decided so please make sure that
you're mentioning the scholarsh
the references as well and it's very
imperative that we set up the meeting
with both of you so please make sure
that you're following this and
you can reach out to us either at
marketing at pi dot bio and if you are
in africa and from any of the african
countries please feel free to reach out
to africa at pine.bio our africa team
works very closely with
us and they will be able to help you and
connect you to the right resources and
you can also
chat with them so thank you aditaio for
sharing this and yes for precision
oncology
we also have a webinar today at 5 00 p.m
in uscst time so if you are in that
time zone or if you feel that that is
quite a good time for you to join
you are welcome to request us to fill up
or please fill up this form here
and we will be sending you the zoom link
for that session
so thank you again everyone for
attending
today's session i do hope that you
enjoyed this session
and i look forward to having all of you
with us again
have a wonderful evening
you